a really common question we always hear
is like how the hell do you go about
managing your time and setting like
almost boundaries right because you want
you want to make your team feel like
you're there to help and you're there to
support them but at the same time you
don't want to be a manager who like
always like gives them the answers
rather than them being given the space
to like find the answers themselves
how how can people go about yeah just
just creating those boundaries and
better managing their time so they can
perform but also give that space to
their team yeah i think it needs to be a
safe place that people come back to you
and go hey i'm struggling or you know
i need help but i think
things like day plans evaluating the day
before being really militantly a day
plan saying what are you trying to
achieve yeah breaking sometimes breaking
up with sprints and saying hey look i
want to achieve this the next couple of
hours cool off you go if you need me i'm
over here yeah um
let's let's review how you got on and
and doing it that way so
i think um
sitting next to someone and watching
them all day is not the answer i think
just being really clear around what that
person is looking to achieve giving them
some guidance around it and then
follow-up is the most underrated thing
in recruitment follow-up i mean if
you're not going to follow up you might
as well not bother setting the person up
in the first place so what so
if me and you sit down in the morning
and you're my manager and say right then
the this is my day plan this is what i'm
aiming to achieve by the end of the day
you're saying like are you making sure
that you tie that together by going
right how do you do that i mean there'll
be
a hundred thousand recruiters that get
set up every day because it's the
manager's job but how often do they sit
down and go through like how did it go
what did you learn what do you need from
me
asking those key questions
[Music]
you